[Musique]
au tout début des années 1970 dans un
temps où l'on croyait encore avec une
naïveté confondante que les ressources
de la terre était illimité un mot
nouveau dérivé de l'américain fait son
irruption dans le dictionnaire de
l'académie française
après de longs débats
depuis ce mot entre les colonnes de
magazines de déco les programmes des
chaînes de télé les paragraphes des
blogs et les hashtag des réseaux sociaux
ce mot est un nom ce nom est féminin
c'est la créativité
si beaucoup de définitions en ont été
donnés tout me semble bien trop longue
aucune ne me semble vraiment complète
d'ailleurs tout le monde trouve que la
créativité est une bonne chose
pourtant si le commandant de bord vous
annonce au décollage que vous pouvez lui
faire confiance car ils pilotent avec
une grande créativité
vous ne ferez pas les fiers d'où ma
tentative de mieux définir ce concept
quitte à le libérer d'un sens qu'il ne
devrait pas avoir je me lance la
créativité c'est l'art de transformer
les nécessités en vertu les nécessités
c'est ce qui s'impose à nous la météo du
jour l'humeur de la boulangère le plus
crevé les vertus c'est ce qui nous est
favorable
l'invention d'un trésor d'une recette de
cuisine ou d'un médicament
à quoi ça sert la créativité
ça sert à nous rendre utiles et à nous
enrichir
dans tous les sens du terme et déjà à ne
pas travailler comme des robots car si
vous travaillez comme des robots je vous
garantis que vous serez remplacés par
des robots
vous ne seriez pas les premiers demandé
au stylo dactylo ou encore au point
sonneurs des lilas alors je décline la
créativité transforme les défauts en
chance c'est ce qu'a su faire l'athlète
olympique
arnaud assoumani qui a fait de la
prothèse de son avant bras manquant un
objet de design iconique jetant un pont
extraordinaire vers le monde du handicap
la créativité transforme les déchets en
ressources
c'est le pari incroyable qu'a fait la
ville de san francisco qui affichera
bientôt un taux de relizane de 100% de
ses ordures ménagères la créativité
transforme des intrus en coéquipiers ce
qui nous donne une piste pour affronter
la crise migratoire ainsi le val de
marne tout proche abruti l'une des plus
grosses unités de production de savon
d'alep issu de la coopération entre des
entrepreneurs français et des maître
savonnier syriens exilés de leur pays en
guerre
la créativité transforme l'utile en
agréable
c'est ainsi que l'on a inventé le plugin
ce sport qui consiste à ramasser les
détritus est garée au bord des chemins
dans la foulée de son jogging offrant
aux sportifs une série de gestes
d'assouplissements variés et impromptus
voyez que la créativité comme
transformation des nécessités en vertu
est simple à formuler et facile à
utiliser
mais sa mise en oeuvre le moment venu
réclame une gymnastique de l'esprit fait
deux sagacité d'humilité et de courage
de courage farce au risque du ridicule
qui frappe si souvent mes propositions
non conventionnelles oui la créativité
est un muscle or un muscle ça se
travaille et ça se travaille tous les
jours et si nous avons un mal fou à
faire face aux défis du monde moderne
au point de le croire bord du désastre
c'est que sous la pression de
l'abondance énergétique
nous avons depuis un siècle et c'est
s'atrophier notre muscles créatif et
pour cause à quoi bon alléger nos engins
de transport lorsque nos énergies
fossiles inépuisable se chargent
l'émouvoir presque gratuitement
à quoi bon se casser la tête à produire
localement lorsque ces mêmes engins de
transport nous livre avec toujours plus
d'intensité de puissance des
marchandises venues du monde entier
à quoi bon affiné optimiser nos
architectures lorsque le béton cette
magnifique pierre liquide permet de
maintenir debout des formes dessinées à
l'abri du vulgaire bon sens à quoi bon
favoriser l'interaction subtil entre les
végétaux
lorsque la chimie de synthèse nous
permet le miracle la monoculture
puis l'allemand à quoi bon faire simple
quand une énergie si abondante permet de
faire si compliqué à quoi peut bien
servir ses capacités d'adaptation
naturel quand nous avons à notre
disposition tant de moyens artificiels
mais des moyens qui nous étouffe qui
dilue notre pulsion de vie qui
pervertissent notre ingéniosité des
moyens qui construisent peu à peu notre
dépendance avant de nous laisser
abassourdi dès lors qu'ils nous ont
lâchés
car ils finissent toujours par moula
chez nous sapiens les avons pris pour
des outils ce n'étaient que des machines
dans l'étang de l'overdose énergétique
la créativité
si attentive si délicate c'est laisser
intimider par l'idéologie absurde de la
machine une véritable machination
alors comment allons-nous réinvestir
notre créativité
déjà il nous faut retrouver le bonheur
des contraintes refuser des hypothèses
simplificatrices qui sont le péché
mignon des technosciences pour ma part
j'ai abandonné le métier d'ingénieur au
profit de celui de designer car le
design authentique lui ne néglige rien
il embrasse et fait la synthèse de trois
contraintes majeures
le bo l'utile et le possible et c'est ce
qui en fait
une discipline de créativité par nature
man mais voici que ce design et cuincy
d'un côté par l'art contemporain qui a
abandonné l'académisme pour produire un
art sans règles et de l'autre côté
l'ingénierie qui s'est spécialisée au
point d'appliquer les règles sans art un
tel clivage ne serait-il pas à la source
du malaise qui semble gagner nos
sociétés industrielles y compris les
plus prospères
ensuite il nous faut retrouver un
rapport immédiat aux choses à l'écouter
à l'observation intime du monde tel
qu'il se présente
victor hugo note en son temps c'est une
triste chose de songer que la nature
parle que le genre humain n'écoute pas
ce genre humain a tellement le nez dans
le guidon technologique que d
opportunité précieuse est évidente lui
échappe
pourquoi at il fallu attendre 1972 avant
d'avoir eu l'idée de mettre des
roulettes sous dialyse
sans doute ce genre humain est il trop
occupé à inventer la star ménagères des
trente glorieuses
j'ai nommé le couteau électrique qu'un
également il nous faut apprendre à
sortir de notre zone de confort
bousculer notre état d'esprit secouer
nos routines lundi mardi ne serait ce
qu'un seul jour sortez de la cage dorée
dans laquelle le confort moderne nous a
enfermés très simple vous prenez une
douche froide
vous allez travailler à pied et vous ne
mangez rien avant 14 notre conscience
sur le quotidien va en être bouleversée
et sans besoin d'un coûteux stage au
tibet mêmes et même pour un coût négatif
enfin il nous faut redonner une place
l'accident a l'opportunité à l'inattendu
qui permettent de faire des découvertes
heureuse par l'entremise du hasard le 3
septembre 1928 le docteur alexandre
fleming rentrer de vacances et observe
que dans les boîtes de pétri qu'il a
laissé en complet d or et moisissures se
sont attaqués aux bactéries de cette
observation faite dans des conditions
pour le moins chaotique et déduire à la
première formule des antibiotiques
al'inverse de cette serendipity
il nous arrive si souvent d'aboutir à
des résultats désastreux est
catastrophique
par l'intermédiaire de moyens
parfaitement rationnel et déterminer
c'est si courant que les auteurs lui en
donner un nom la zamboni t
à propos de zamboni t je ne sais pas si
vous savez mais nous sommes en train de
remplir nos océans de plastique
la plupart de ces objets colonisateur et
mortifère pour l'écosystème sont aux
normes issues de technologies avancées
de transformation du pétrole
fabriqués dans des usines gérer avec
précision
dessiné par des bureaux d'études
reconnus pour leur savoir faire
le tout transporter par une logistique
impeccable une succession parfaitement
ordonné de processus rationnel cartésien
et déterministe qui transforme en étant
mis bout à bout et à la vitesse des
temps modernes et de façon parfaitement
prévisible nos milieux marins en simple
poubelle zemble alité or une partie
substantielle de ce plastique est issu
de nos détergents gel douche shampoings
pour le shampoing je plaide non coupable
des bouteilles et des flacons des doses
voir des verts soeur des pressoirs que
nous avons massivement adopté pour leur
attrait prétendument moderne le bon
vieux blocs de savon baveux et poisseux
ne correspondront plus à nos
superstition hygiéniste
pourtant la solution pour un savon plus
nettes étaient sous nos yeux depuis
longtemps il y a dix ans je me suis lavé
les mains
je me laisse sur hull avait depuis je me
suis lavé les mains avec du savon solide
parce que j'ai toujours trouvé que
c'était moins cher et j'ai découvert que
la banque s'était meilleur pour la peau
est meilleure pour l'environnement
sauf que au moment de prendre le bloc de
savon la coupelle porte-savon est venu
avec
une fois de plus alors je me suis dit
visiblement se porte le savent on veut
coller aux saveurs apparemment c'est un
problème mais sous certaines conditions
relatives à sa taille à sa géométrie est
sa matière ceci pourrait devenir une
solution
le porte savon le plus logique de
l'histoire devrait faire ce qu'il sait
naturellement faire de mieux
quelques années après cette étincelle
mon équipe de rêve a mis au point le
plus petit porte savon du monde 1,4 g de
résine végétale qui font corps avec le
savon est lui à dos trois petits pilotis
qui le maintiendront à l'abri de
l'humidité stagnante
pendant tout son usage
comme il est très simple il est facile à
fabriquer comme il est facile à
fabriquer il peut facilement faire face
aux coûts d'une production locale et
disons le une production française comme
il est tout petit il est incassable
il incarne à mon sens la mission sacrée
du designer qui n'est pas d'aller re
décorer les yachts des nababs mais de
relever le plus grand défi de notre
époque résoudre d'un même mouvement les
problèmes de fin de monde et les
problèmes de fin de mois
ainsi avec cette créativité qui n'est
pas là pour apporter une solution au
problème et pour transformer le problème
en solution pour nous confirmer la
conjecture d'henry ford une poignée
d'hommes parvient à s'enrichir
simplement en prêtant attention à des
détails que la plupart des gens
négligent alors la prochaine fois qu'un
appel micro vous informe de ce que le
pilote de votre avion c'est faire preuve
de créativité
dites-vous que sa capacité à prêter
attention au moindre détail à réagir
positivement à l'inattendu à saisir en
temps réel les opportunités qui lui sont
offertes peuvent vous sauver la vie
dites vous bien que la créativité n'a
rien à voir avec l'originalité mais tout
à voir avec la pertinence que sous ses
faux airs de fantaisie gratuite elle est
une école de sagesse et d'utilité
restent eux trois questions et vous ce
soir demain la semaine prochaine quels
sont les minuscules détails auxquels
vous allez tout à coup prêter attention
quels sont les défauts que vous allez
transformer en chance
quels sont les nécessités que vous allez
transformer en vertu bon soin
[Applaudissements]